Alabama's Republican Senate candidate is
fighting back against allegations of
sexual misconduct for women told The
Washington Post that retired judge Roy
Moore pursued them when they were
teenagers and he was in his 30s one of
them was 14 at the time all four have
confirmed their stories to CBS News more
angrily rejected calls yesterday to
abandon his campaign which could have
national implications Paula Reid is
following the story and she's in our
Washington bureau Paula good morning
good morning Roy Moore is running in a
special election next month for the seat
of former Senator Jeff Sessions who is
of course now Attorney General the
Republicans currently hold a 52-48
majority in the Senate and this was
supposed to be an easy win for the GOP
but these new allegations have many of
more supporters second-guessing their
endorsements these allegations are
completely false false and misleading
with pressure mounting on Roy Moore to
step aside and it's allegations of
sexual misconduct
Alabama's Republican candidate for
Senate gave his side of the story I
believe they're politically motivated I
believe they're brought only to stop a
very successful campaign that's what
they're doing Moore said he dated a lot
of young ladies upon his return from the
military service but denied UT lead
Portman who told The Washington Post nor
touched her inappropriately and she was
14 years old I've never talked to her
never had any contact with her Moore
admits he remembers the other two women
in the post story
Debbie Wesson Gibson and Gloria taker
decent but denies going out on dates or
giving them alcohol after Moore's radio
interview with sean hannity senators
Mike Lee and Steve Daines
rescinded their endorsements and the
Republican Senate campaign committee
stopped raising money for Roy Moore on
the ground reactions from Alabamans were
mixed it's very disgusting that a grown
man would take advantage of a child I
plant somebody started this whether it's
true or not just to ruin his chances of
being
like state representative ed Henry
criticized Moore's accusers and said it
his day who should be prosecuted Henry
told a local newspaper if they believe
this man is predatory they are guilty of
allowing him to exist for 40 years
Republican state auditor Jim Ziegler
defended Moore by invoking the Bible
stating Mary was a teenager when Joseph
was an adult carpenter they became the
parents of Jesus there is nothing
immoral or illegal here Ziegler said in
an interview but the president was less
forgiving of more press secretary Sarah
Sanders spoke for mr. Trump who was
traveling in Asia if these allegations
are true the worry for Republicans now
is that this could open the door for a
democratic win in deep red Alabama it's
too late to take more stay off the
ballot but they could try to run someone
else as a write-in candidate however
that's always risky especially since
Moore is unwilling to drop out at this
point
Alex Paula Reid in Washington thanks
Paula